the idea of talking trees has been
capturing the human imagination for
generations my bark is worse than my
bite okay so maybe they don't talk to us
but it turns out trees can talk to each
other speaking to each other but that
does beg the question what do trees have
to talk about and can we learn to speak
their language underneath the soil a
vast and interconnected network of life
links the trees through their root
systems but they can't talk to each
other without help the whole process
starts with hub trees the oldest and
tallest tree is in the forest
sub trees have greater access to
sunlight and through the process of
photosynthesis end up producing more
sugar than they actually need
underground fungi need sugar to survive
most of their bodies are made out of a
mass of threads called mycelium they
grow within the root system of trees to
absorb the excess sugars in return the
mycelium provides the tree with the
nutrients it needs from the soil this
symbiotic relationship is known as micro
raisa which stems from the Greek words
for fungus and root
these tree fungi relationships connect
the trees in the forest together forming
an underground communication network to
exchange water and nutrients
to nurture their seedlings
and even send warning signals when under
threat so how many trees are really
talking to each other to get a better
picture of these forest relationships a
team of researchers used DNA analysis to
map a fungal Network in a patch of
Canadian forest remarkably they found
that one tree was connected to 47 other
trees their models also showed that when
hug trees were removed it would cause
more connections to be lost than if
trees were simply removed randomly
[Music]
studying these kinds of underground
exchanges will play a vital role in
creating stronger more resilient forests
for the future
so even though we might not be able to
talk to trees at least we can still keep
trying to understand their language who
knows what they might say
[Music]
[Music]